-Guys, do you ever see a photo
in the news
and think the headline
could be much better?
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"News and Improved."
Here we go.
-♪ "News and Improved" ♪
-For example,
check out this first photo.
The original headline was...
The headline can definitely
be improved,
'cause if you only
looked at the photo,
the headline could have been...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Check out this next photo here.
The original headline was...
But if you only
looked at the photo,
the headline could have been...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Up next, this headline says...
Headline could have been...
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's so bummed.
-That kid left.
-Yes.
"And now the teachers
would like
to perform something."
-Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
-Why?
We know they can dance.
We just want to see
the kids dance, please.
-And we'd like to thank
our teachers again.
-With another reprise
of their dance.
The next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Cheers and applause ]
"You see, the second-quarter
numbers are here.
We gotta get them up here."
[ Laughter ]
Up next, this headline says...
Headline could have been...
[ Cheers and applause ]
We've all done it.
Got to learn the hard way.
This next headline was...
Headline could have been...
-Wow!
[ Applause ]
-Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
It's like...
[ Applause ]
And finally,
this headline was...
Headline could have been...
That's all the time we have
for "News and Improved."